[Music]
hi guys and welcome to another episode
of congratulations
[Music]
520
600 minutes
[Music]
how about
[Music]
dude um you know
uh
wow did we have a [ __ ] crazy week uh
crystallia.com for tickets i will be in
dallas
soon i will be in wichita
soon i will be in uh atlanta
soon chris leah.com for tickets i will
be in washington dc soon
stockton and oakland
california
uh raleigh savannah georgia denver
boston we got a bunch of dates coming up
florida one's in florida
albany
new york new york new york new york
um
start spreading the news
one fires [ __ ]
text went off one fire that's the reason
one fire subscribe to our channel love
it if you do that you know i will tell
you uh we've got
we got hit with the [ __ ] you have to
sign in now to watch some of our
episodes i don't know if it's because
i'm saying too many bad words or what
but it sucks man so uh you know last
week our our views got hit in half
because of it so we got to do the this
cult's got to do the extra work dude you
know you gotta we don't mind because we
we you know we're we're we're one day
going to build that log cabin so you
know signing in isn't a big deal on
youtube because they're restricting our
videos but i will say dude we got to do
that extra work and you got to just text
your friend if everybody were just to
text one friend hey check this out boom
views double you understand
so we do the work my babies
and if we don't
all good the oops button chrisalia.com
but um you know we have we have a good
time just gotten alert that it's
independence day today happy fourth of
july but this will come out in a few
days love that the [ __ ] connection is
weak on my headphones on fire but it's
all good um and we're all good so um
yeah dude look at that box it comes in
it's really nice look at that it just
comes in a beautiful box like that it
just comes in a beautiful box just like
that
with the beautiful and when i say
beautiful i mean
just absolutely
gorgeous look at that beautiful box
it's an explosion from what you might
not know
the um
what the fight companion that we did
went
stupid viral
so we put out the oops grenade
graphics and they went stupid viral
and we put out it features
four original
oops only
audio clips
we vow to never lose the rhythm to
your conversation ever
again
you will never lose it if you're talking
and somebody interrupts you
you will never
lose the rhythm to your conversation
again they now you
i they these are flying off the shelves
i love the qvc [ __ ] they are absolutely
that red button right there it's
beautiful it's vibrant isn't it
double ops that is just vibrant you go
to chrisley.com all subliminal while
supplies left tired of your friends
always interrupting you
well there you go those days are over
those days are
they're done do we have can we get
they're always
we are you tired of your friends always
interrupting you do we have can we talk
do we have can we we can make them for
just
15
can we
okay we can't go lower actually they
won't let us apparently it's a
can we
okay
um
whenever they look back on the things
when they're selling [ __ ] the guy's just
literally going like this
can we okay we can't okay
can we do you know what we're gonna do
we're gonna do
one easy payment
screaming
fifteen dollars that's what we're gonna
do
it's like that uh austin powers i cannot
control this ahead of my voice um
so anyway dude and we got the patreon
firing and all syllables go on over to
patreon.com um
so it's great pride month is over always
feels funny when all those [ __ ]
companies are like all right never mind
our real logo
never mind a real logo
we don't care that
we we do it for bags but
that was cute
here's our real logo
back it's black and white and again now
it's just blue now
now it's just red
it's orange and that's it it's one of
the colors of the rainbows um
so pride month is over i love that that
day that everyone just [ __ ] is like
all right just [ __ ] straight up june
1st just everything gets a little less
colorful and uh
so
that sucks dude honestly that pride
month is over because i [ __ ] missed
it dude i wanted to decorate so badly
and i just [ __ ] missed it dude
[ __ ] man
dude i was gonna [ __ ] decorate so
much i was gonna put rainbows all over
and i [ __ ] missed it
now it's too goddamn late dude so if
you're with me dude
i get it man i was gonna [ __ ]
decorate my whole house god damn it i
was gonna pass out [ __ ] flyers
i [ __ ] missed it dude i guess i'll
wait till next year
i was at the [ __ ] um
air we went to [ __ ] london dude
we went to london oh [ __ ] dude we
[ __ ] absolutely went to london we
infiltrated london that's what we did
our [ __ ] we were two americans
infiltrating london oh [ __ ] dude ah we
saw big ben oh [ __ ] we saw it from the
plane and we saw it from the london eye
oh for [ __ ] sake we also saw it from
the ground oh god
they saw it three different ways jesus
christ they saw it from above from below
and absolutely in the middle of for
[ __ ] sake dude
that's just absolute but we saw big ben
and b guess what we learned big ben
doesn't even [ __ ] refer to the clock
it refers to whatever something [ __ ]
inside the clock oh for [ __ ] sake and
he saw it from all different angles and
even though he saw it from all different
angles kristen kept saying look and he
and he did every time oh god damn it
even though he saw it he kept getting
the [ __ ] hey look
but it's all good dude we took the
london eye and that was the most
touristy [ __ ] we did too uh we went to
london and i got to the airport and um
they [ __ ] canceled we were in that
american airlines thing that just
canceled all of our flight this is going
to be the best episode ever dude i have
so much to talk about i can't wait to
get it we have a lot to discuss
like when news when [ __ ] programs you
know we got a lot to discuss here and
then they just talk about like rihanna's
dress
you know i can't wait to get into this
actually because we have a lot to go
over um
the guy who hosts [ __ ] whatever that
show is what was he wearing um so uh
uh blake who's the country singer the
[ __ ] guy
blake shelton the most [ __ ] he's
never felt a level of insecurity at all
just always [ __ ] just like what oh
who cares man they don't like me that's
great
you don't like this outfit oh [ __ ] man
whatever maybe i'll wear it again maybe
i won't you know [ __ ] you know
if i guess if i want to i will
[ __ ]
how much has you [ __ ] eight women um
in his life um so
yeah dude so the guy says so i get to
the airport
american airlines was just all of a
sudden they go flight's canceled
great so we go online what do we do no
wait sorry we were at the airport and
the flight got canceled kristin goes hey
look look what happened she got a text
canceled dude go to the desk now i'm
ready you know me i'm rip roaring right
you know me i'm rip roaring i'm ready to
go but she says com you know maybe this
is going to be a good she's got this new
saying that is like an old saying that's
like good news bad news who knows bad
news good news who knows and they're
like sometimes bad news is good news you
just have no [ __ ] idea and i'm like
okay fair enough you know
so uh i go up and do the guy couldn't
have been nicer and i kept it cool and
it couldn't have been nicer the guy at
jetblue it's called jetblue y or some
[ __ ] [ __ ] why why it's called
like jetblue it's like a station of
jetblue that they have
where you go and everything's [ __ ] up
it's not called like you like uh
customer service they call it some [ __ ]
like why did this happen or something
jetblue how come i don't even know what
it's called jetblue oops it's called
[ __ ] i don't know what it is but we
went to the desk
and this lady did the thing where even
though i was first you cut a line and it
was fine whatever because everyone's all
[ __ ] and i was like what are we gonna
do dude and we had a layover in jfk and
instead dude they gave us a [ __ ]
straight shot dude they made up for it
straight shot baby
so we did it got to london
in the airport dude i was in the airport
and i was like i'm gonna go get some
water and i go to get a [ __ ] i could
get that smart water you know
so the guy at the thing
he was like this dude that was making so
many jokes to people
and he says to
me i get there and he says now has
anyone told you
and i go here we go
here we go
and it's all good
this is the life that i lead here we go
and he says has anyone told you
something you don't know before
and i said
it was one of those sentence that
it felt like
oh oh okay so
this is not okay somebody whoops
somebody stole my brain
i
i'm just
what's going on i'm looking for my brain
because here's the thing that sentence
is one of those things that like when
you you know when you look at those
paintings with the artist and they do
like they do paintings of like somebody
with two sets of eyes and you're like
are there
you know
is there one or what if
it's just
it's like a thing like if you look up a
artist who puts two sets of eyes like
one right on top of each other it's like
a [ __ ] some artist does that and you
look at him and you're just like is it
and you know there's four eyes but
you're still like there's two wait it's
my mind is just
or like they'll have like does this
shape fit in this thing or this thing
and you're like well that one's way
smaller but it fits in both and you're
like but how does
what is it and
it's like an optical illusion but for
four words he did it he didn't this
[ __ ] did an optical illusion
with words dude he says has anyone told
you something you don't know before and
at first i think well
uh
yeah
because
all that would be is like hey you know
flounders have two eyes on only one side
of their body and no eyes on the other
oh
that's something i didn't know before
somebody told me that or i read it
so yes
but then i think
but the only answer to that is yes
because no matter who you are
somebody's told you something you don't
know before
so it can't be what he means right
unless
somebody stole my brain
and i just can't figure it out
so instead
i feel like i i realize the only thing
that i can possibly say to this man
is what
because then surely he'll clear it up
so he says to me has anyone told you
something you don't know before
and then i quickly assess the situation
with the brain that is still in my head
and i hit him with
what
and then he says
has anyone told you
something you don't know before
so now
i'm [ __ ]
because he doubled down
this is what he meant
but surely he's behind a counter so he
deals with people and deals with things
and situations so he's capable i guess
and i'm just holding the [ __ ] smart
water
and so i say
well
what
do you mean
and he says
you really resemble keanu reeves
and i say oh yeah well
i have heard that before
and he says yeah
and i said well that's not so bad he's
cool and he says yeah
hey guy
just tell me i look like keanu reeves
has anyone told you something that's
when my friend walked up to this [ __ ]
chick and he and he meant to say like
hey
have we met before or something or
whatever instead he wrote he walked up
to her and said do you know who i am
right now dude and we never forgot it
man do you know who i am right
[Laughter]
now jake but also i'm always jake um
dude i went into the pool the other day
i feel like here's the thing dude i have
an assistant and some and she uses our
pool sometimes which is [ __ ] radical
i love it because the pool gets used and
uh she told me that the [ __ ] uh pool
guy was like
oh there's a shortage on chlorine and
like whatever dude there there's always
a shortage on everything now ever since
covid and they making it up half the
time you know they're making it up
they'll be like there's a shortage on
[ __ ] there's actually a shortage on
coca-cola or [ __ ] water you know and
you're like really yeah there's a
shortage on cardboard boxes ever since
got it you can't get anything if you
want to get
so there's a shortage on chlorine so i
just got to take it because i don't know
what am i going to pretend i know more
about pools than this [ __ ] so
i'm like okay well when when can we get
it he's like probably a month or two i
said can we swim in our pool and he says
sure it's fine it's not a big deal and
it's gonna have like a big party and
just don't [ __ ] in it
then i say well you know about the anus
thing like sometimes just with your
anuses if you got a little diarrhea in
it on your ankle sometimes the anus has
[ __ ] pebbles on it you can't help it and
then it's just in the pool what if it's
in there and it goes well it's fine you
know just don't be [ __ ] in the pool
so i'm like all right cool we won't get
in the pool but i have a two-year-old i
gotta make sure he's not sitting in the
pool
and we get [ __ ] you know we all get
[ __ ] up but
i get in the pool and i get to pull with
calvin the next day boom i wake up my
uvula is swollen yes dude
yes
my uvula is swollen now does that sound
for those of you that don't know what a
uvula is does it sound like something
that resides in a course it does is it
no it's the back thing in the [ __ ] that
hangs out from the back of your [ __ ]
okay in the mouth when you all the
cartoons when they go ah and the camera
looks in it you see that you have your
dangling that little [ __ ] that that
[ __ ] uh what do you call it the the
the boxing [ __ ] the speed bag that
little speed bag in the back your mouth
that's called the uvula it doesn't
reside in a put resides in your mouth
the only time it resides in a put
i guess is when someone's being bored
because they have a uv layer in their
mouth but anyway
too far
but anyway
so um
well this is gonna be restricted this
video but it's all good my babies share
it with somebody share it with somebody
but that was also medical and science
and this is a uvula and they do reside
where i said before if they didn't catch
me the first time but they resided where
they said before
uh where i said before so i get out of
the pool the next day i wake up swelling
you of your life yes dude [ __ ] yeah man
whoa
and i say to my assistant great i got a
[ __ ] thing from the algae in my pool
and she's like she laughs you know
because she knows me she's like he
didn't get the [ __ ] thing from that
algae in your pool and i was like okay
well i'm just saying dude they got a
chlorine shortage and the [ __ ] pool
guy's being lazy and he can't hook us up
with the chlorine [ __ ] it's like it's
crack cocaine we gotta find a new guy a
new dealer
and we can't get it in the pool
and uh she's like it's fine
so okay so a few weeks go by i get in
the pool again dude the day before we go
to london i wake up
[ __ ] yeah dude got a speed bag in the
back of my mouth again
swollen uvula time
baby swollen [ __ ] uvula time dude
this time it's fat as [ __ ] dude this
time
i can lay it flat on the back of my
tongue it looks like jabba the hut okay
your boy's got a swollen uvula it's
disgusting but i go okay last time it
lasted a day let's hope it only lasts a
day because then i'm going to be nervous
about bringing covert to [ __ ]
to all the people who [ __ ] you know
because your boy went to london
i got [ __ ] covered i'm spreading
covered all around different angles of
[ __ ] big pen you know i don't want
that right
the next day i wake up youvel is gone so
she says and all of a sudden my
assistant just says it's not the pool i
said well it's just a coincidence that
it happened two times and she said look
if it happens four times then it maybe
is your pull and i was like what what
the [ __ ] you just making some [ __ ] up
willy nilly she's like four times means
that so i'll let you know next two times
if i got a [ __ ] speed back that's
just relaxing on the back of my tongue
dude
like jabba the hut after i get out the
pool because chlorine there's a chlorine
shortage
i don't know it's like has anyone told
you something that you don't know before
so uh that's what's been happening in my
life and then i get to the [ __ ] thing
and there's a flight delay dude and i'm
at the flight delay and dude check this
out they got to do we got the straight
shot but so i had a first the first leg
of my [ __ ]
was the guy was so helpful dude he was
super helpful the first leg of my [ __ ]
was
la
to
jfk and then the second and that was
jetblue mint we sit back we relax we
have a good time we go we go horizontal
if i can't go horizontal in a flight i
ain't going all right yeah it costs bags
but dude
okay there's a difference between being
uncomfortable when you arrive and
[ __ ] being super spry and cool and
keeping it nice and in a good mood
because you laid horizontal right
um
so we get a
all the way to jfk we land and then we
gotta board an american airlines flight
from jfk to heathrow ally okay now
we
all the american airlines did something
happen with their computer and like
overnight they canceled 12 000 flights
in june
or july
12 000 flights in july they just
canceled them got all [ __ ] up we all
have to rebook so i go to the [ __ ]
jet blue whoopsie daisy or whatever the
[ __ ] the thing is called did you look it
up what it's called
jet blue how come jet blue oops jet blue
wow that's what the sign says ginkgo
oops um
so uh
i get to i get to the thing and he's
like um
okay so the flight's canceled canceled
we're gonna miss our connection so so
what do we do and i'm ready for him so
this is your fault so what do we do and
he says oh god and i go great and he
says
we don't have another flight to london
for another two days and i say well at
that point we'll just have to come back
around immediately so what are we gonna
do and he says let me look you know what
i can do you know what it's a connecting
flight let me actually see if i can call
them
to
in jfk to hold the flight until you land
and i say
what
and he says
so in some cases i i'm able to call and
have them hold up a plane
if you're not going to make a connection
or something like that
and i'm like
is this a
famous thing or
[Music]
he says sometimes we can do it and i say
and it's like legal and
you guys can actually do this you've
done it before and he says oh yeah
and i'm like
oh
airlines are full of [ __ ]
sorry we can't open the door you're late
oh no you're full of [ __ ] i just found
out dude because some really nice gay
man behind the [ __ ] jet blue oopsy
daisy station told me that you can hold
up a [ __ ] flight just cause
oh sorry we closed the door oh no no no
no have you ever been to jetblue oopsy
daisy in lax in terminal five no you
haven't talked to the very nice gay man
probably and ask him to hold up the
plane
open the door
i don't know if you know that they can
do that but they can do that dude and
then i came back and asked my assistant
about it because she used to be a flight
attendant and she said yes they can do
that and i go where's everyone hiding
this information dude it's [ __ ]
so i got on the plane
straight shot he got us a straight shot
so now we're on the plane ten and a half
hours i watch movies bro i'm so excited
to watch movies and just do nothing lay
horizontal and watch [ __ ] movies i
watch bad movies good i watch bad movies
pretty much on the bad movies i saw what
did i see i saw one night in soho which
is edgar wright movie um
i love edgar wright movies this one
wasn't for me i saw
oh dude i saw two
other movies eternals which by the way i
know it bombed i guess but i i i
like
it's definitely one of the better marvel
movies and let me tell you another thing
too
that dude kumao
is my favorite
he is my favorite comedic comedic actor
he's my favorite comedic actor i want to
say he's my favorite actor but i've
never seen him do like [ __ ] i i like
like king speech [ __ ] i've only seen him
be like kind of funny and [ __ ] that dude
is so funny that dude nails comedy in
movies it's he is so good kumail is my
favorite comedic actor period that guy
is so good in movies i love that
[ __ ] okay
if i see you know i'm gonna watch any
movie he's in now that's that's i'm
gonna watch it he's my new [ __ ] um
michael douglas or leo you put michael
douglas in a movie bro it could be about
anne frank and he'll play the lead and
i'll watch that [ __ ]
you put liam neeson in the movie you put
that
cocknose [ __ ] in a movie your
boy will wait till it comes out on dvd
and [ __ ] put it in his tray or
whatever streaming you know
i'll get [ __ ] roku for it i'll watch
every i've seen every liam neeson movie
bro i just watched black light or
whatever the hell that movie was
terrible dude they phoned it in dude
they should honestly make a liam neeson
movie called phone in the phone-in
and he's just like he's just running
after bad guys and you don't even know
what they did because basically that's
where they're at already
you don't even know where they did and
like
like
like they honestly they should kidnap
the bad guy should kidnap somebody and
then he should be like i've got to get
the girl and then halfway through i
think you should switch to calling them
bank robbers even though they didn't rob
a bank and like just be like we got to
get the money back and then the girl
disappears you're not in it anymore and
then at the end he gets all the money
back and like keep some for the wife
that's dying like slides her off some
[ __ ] to get an operation
and you're and you just don't give a
[ __ ] because it's called the phone in
and every other line is i guess i don't
know i i don't really remember i didn't
listen i didn't read the script really
sure
that's the la most of the lines are sure
let's get him
um
and uh
so i watched eternals and it was [ __ ]
you know the one of the better marvel
movies and then um
i watched the green knight dude
sup
hey i watched that movie that hollywood
loved the green knight hey
wow didn't even mean to
hey didn't even mean to hit the button
hey i watched the green night that the
[ __ ] academy lauded hey sup
[Laughter]
i saw the green knight with that guy dev
patel or whatever from hereditary and
they [ __ ] put him in it the guy's
[ __ ] he's playing a white guy he's
indian dude whatever got no problem with
that one equal opportunity for everyone
but saw the movie and got one quest
sup
that movie man
did you see it
oh man i was halfway through getting
mighty pissed off just like sup
sup i'm watching the movie sup dude sup
i'm watching a movie i'm like [ __ ]
nicholas cajun that one scene that he
had definitely ad-libbed in in the
[ __ ] movie that was remade by uh the
one that used to be a harvard guy tell
bad lieutenant or whatever and now he
remade it and it's nicholas cage he
walks into the guy and he keeps saying
sup sup something i was trying to do his
lines nicholas cage is like sup dude
that's me watching green night cause
hollywood
shop
dude i i
i mean in the in the movie dude all
right so look i'm watching a movie and
i'm gonna get to the london trip i'll
get to it dude
because boy do i have some good [ __ ]
about that and this podcast might be
extra long but dude i'll get to it but
so i'm watching the green knight dude
and in the beginning dude it's king
arthur who's white and then he's got a
nephew that's indian for some reason or
whatever it is don't mean to be racist
but i just said i like kamel so it's all
good dude
sup
now i'm watching the [ __ ] green
knight and
dev patel or whatever his [ __ ] name
is
um that sounds like a color in a crayola
box his name
oh can you get me the dev patel
please the burnt dev patel and so uh so
so i get the [ __ ]
uh
i'm watching the movie and dev patel's
there and king arthur is like dying he's
playing somebody who definitely played a
james bond bill and no question dude no
question this guy played a james bond
villain whoever the king arthur guy is
and all he does is talk miles because
he's dying or whatever a british
and uh dev patel comes and there's
christmas and they're all making merry
which is a phrase that [ __ ] went out
which we got to bring back dude
and um
while they're eating making murray
um
they're in a circular table and then
this [ __ ] green
tree
giant
knight
comes in on a [ __ ] green horse with a
green axe and a branch
now i'm like k
but i'm like hey hollywood and alrighty
i'm like okay i'm in dude i'm in i'm in
right you got king arthur's probably a
james bond villain and then you got an
in like a [ __ ]
not a white nephew and it's why but also
i'm in dude
and then a tree guy walks in on a horse
that's also green and i'm like
this now this is my kind of motion
picture
right i'm not yet at this hey hollywood
sup level i'm not there yet right
so the green giant [ __ ] the green
knight comes in and says
whatever he says this is the gist of it
he says
you know because it's all british and
[ __ ] and it's all it's almost like
they're talking like shakespeare and i'm
just like i don't even know what they're
saying but i happen to know because i'm
just horizontal in a pod right at the
[ __ ] jet blue [ __ ]
and i'm watching the thing so
i'm really paying attention there's
nothing else going on
so uh
the green knight guy says to the [ __ ]
def could no no he says to king arthur
one of your men basically i
he's i'll can we do a game you know it's
like
[ __ ] saw
it's like can we play a game and king
arthur is like as long as it's fun and
it's not you're not coming
for any ill will and the guy's like no i
want to i want to do a game
and so he's like okay and he's like
anyone can
any one of your guys can strike me with
their sword and the only thing i ask
well however they strike me i return the
favor in 12 months
and it's like just say a year but i get
it back then you had to be more
descriptive but okay
but i'm like wow what a stupid [ __ ]
game and the guy traveled how long to
come do this and he's a tree so i'm not
yet at sup level i'm not yet asking
hollywood hey hollywood sup i'm in but
where's this going dude right okay
where's it going so
king arthur says does any one of my men
want to partake in this game and make
merry and i'm like okay and then dev
patel jumps in didn't meet did you know
nobody saw this coming because he was
like he's like a 20 year old or some
[ __ ] and all the men were like maybe
i'll do it and dev patel's like i'll
[ __ ] do it and he comes in and the
[ __ ] tree guy just kneels on the
[ __ ]
ground and dev patel's like you sure you
don't want to fight and the tree guy is
like do your worst and [ __ ] death
patel laps his head off dude
so now i'm like i'm in
man i'm so focused it's like i took
ginkgo
[ __ ] bloba in this pod okay
so i'm watching in the airplane and i'm
horizontal watching this [ __ ] and i'm
just you know there's a little bit of
turbulence but i'm watching the green
night and i'm like oh wow
wow this is really [ __ ] interesting
and it's so odd and i can't believe i'm
not asking a hollywood sup yet
boom
hello hi how much longer till we get
there
so now i'm like sup with this [ __ ]
but the green knight isn't falling down
he's staying on his knees so i'm like
intrigued
you know
and the turbulence lightens up okay all
right all right okay
and the green knight gets up with no
head
he stands up like it's a chicken
he just stands up like i don't need a
head like a chicken when you lap it off
and they run around they're just like
what head
and he picks up his head
and the head says
meet me in 12 months
and he gets on his green horse
and rides away
some like
hmm
i guess i'm in
better not unravel
but i'm in
you wound it so tight i'm in where are
we going
so then halfway through the movie
dev patel's like guess i gotta go you
know what i mean he's like santa arthur
should i go do this game
do you think he meant it and arthur's
like i don't know it's only for you to
find out and i'm just like don't go
your head's gonna get lopped off he
obviously knows magic
because he walked around and picked up
his head and left and went to his green
chapel that you got to meet him
at
and so he's like but it's honorable to
go and dev patel's like [ __ ] yeah i'm
gonna go and he goes dude and the whole
movie is about him going for six days
six nights to try and get to the green
chapel he just meets different people
and [ __ ] he meets somebody that robs him
he meets giants that are just walking
and i'm talking about uh attack on titan
giants and he's like where are you going
and the giant is like and just keeps
walking and it's just
having these scenes around like
willy-nilly and at this point i'm like
sup okay and i google it because i got
the wi-fi it's free at jetblue and i
find out it was a [ __ ] poem that was
written in the year 1400 or whatever the
and i'm like oh dude you're gonna make a
movie that was written by some jerk-off
in the year 1400 and it was just a poem
taking so much liberty
i started reading the poem i didn't know
what it meant it was like and i'm like
give me a break dude and at this point
i'm looking at hollywood and i'm like
sup and everyone's pretending to like it
because dev patel isn't it he's a hot
new thing and i'm like sup though man
and it got nominated for like 20
different awards and i'm like sup though
man
not just the bafta
sup
no we don't watch this movie
so that's my review of green
[ __ ] night
i give it 10
subs
i listen to so many [ __ ] breakdowns
of the movie afterwards man it really
made me question things and i know that
people say well you know a piece of art
a good piece of art makes you talk about
i'm like all right cool whatever dude
but still
stop
make movies that just make sense or kind
of don't make sense or if you don't you
better nail it you better david lynch
that [ __ ] dude
so we got to london
into that londoner hotel londoner
london huh
checked in and they were just like
ah how's it going
we're like cool
we liked the hotel it was nice as [ __ ]
and it was pride there by the way still
which i didn't i don't understand oh
there's a [ __ ] time delay or some
[ __ ]
we were jet lagged and i was like i
don't know
and uh but so many just
proud
gays just walking around which is great
and uh
we get there and he's like so that's a
mistake and i'm like great dude we
travel 11 hours i had to watch the
[ __ ] goddamn green knight
and he's just like
uh let me try and fix it
could just hang out at the cafe for a
second i'm like sure you know i [ __ ]
love cafe so i guess sat there he came
back and said we fixed it don't worry
and that's on us that we made a mistake
don't worry
and so we got to the room
and it was nice and you know
we set up some dinners and [ __ ] let me
tell you something about the food at uh
in london
now i [ __ ] on it before in my podcast
plenty of times because food in london
as a general rule basically sucks but we
went to some restaurants that were like
the top-notch restaurants and they were
[ __ ]
absolutely banging dude like just great
just
amazing
and
then we whenever we would be like oh
let's get let's pop in here and get
something to eat it was like eating
a [ __ ] like i might as well have been
eating fabric
like
i don't understand if you just go to
some restaurant it's like someone just
[ __ ] lowers your jaw
and
bottoms out inside you just
like it's like someone goes can you sit
um just
and then let me just
let me just get there so your nose is
right on the bottom of my anus and then
here lower your here and i'll just grab
your jaw and open it and then just
just in
down your and they ride your face and
they're just like ah there we go all
right cool that'll be 25 pounds
i mean they just it's like they just
[ __ ] down your throat
and you just take it and you pay for it
like whatever their version of sweet
greens is forget it
just straight down your [ __ ]
up you're trying to get away there whoop
up
up keep the nose right at the back of my
anus
and um
yeah but the top-notch restaurants like
we went to cafe
mario mario i say because i'm from
jersey
was great
uh we went to another place called
uh above at hyde which they were like do
you want this five course meal or the
seven q there's only two things you
could order they were like do you want
the five course meal or the seven course
meal and i'm like well you're gonna
[ __ ] ask this in front of my girl
i mean come on dude
slide me a note okay guys
girl dude
i can eat what you say so i'm going to
take i'm going to [ __ ] out
i'm going to do the
you can ask that's a little disrespect i
mean yeah she's a [ __ ] prada outfit
like how am i going to
five like are you
do you have a nine course meal i want
that one give me the seven course meals
twice i want 14 courses
so i say seven and i say it with because
i'm like dude you're not gonna this is
says okay
here we go hope you're ready the [ __ ]
that they [ __ ] first of all dude
one thing was like an egg with yolk in
it i guess and another thing was like a
bar of soap
and
one thing was a [ __ ] piece of ice
cream on and on an ice cube and it was
just like
and it was good but also
relax
you know these [ __ ] restaurants but
it's about an experience it's about a
culinary experience yeah well make it
experience [ __ ] really nice from my
mouth and my wallet how about
and i don't need to be like oh visual
the visual [ __ ] give me the food you
know but it was all about what it was
about it was a beautiful time and you
know we laughed
and uh
so yeah we had the seven course meal at
above hide and uh
we did um
what else did we do the [ __ ] god
the night it was it's i mean the jet lag
[ __ ] is unbelievable
like it was like we landed and it was a
different time and then we didn't know
jet lag i don't know how much of it is
actual jet lag just because you were in
the air and those you know because being
jet lag is not about the time difference
it's about being up in the air and being
if you look it up if you google it i
mean someone will explain it way better
than i can but um
there was that and then also the time
difference so i don't know how much of
it was the sleep difference or how much
of it was the [ __ ] jet lag yeah the
actual jet lag got it so hot in here um
but
uh
i finally would like fall asleep
and then like when i would wake up in
the middle at night it wouldn't be like
regular waking up like what it would be
like
like that i would do two and i would
look and i would be i was just slept for
sleep for two hours and i'm like should
i get up or
not even knowing what time it is
but the worst part about the [ __ ]
thing was
like
the bathroom that they had was just it
was one of those bathrooms that was like
way too nice
that it
was annoying
like
the toilet like the second you walk into
the bathroom the toilet goes
[Music]
and like sometimes
you go to the bathroom not to even use
the toilet
sometimes you want to brush your teeth
or wash your hands or just take a break
so that's fine when you walk in the
bottom because you're already awake
[Music]
but then you can't close the top
without forcing it so you'd leave it
and then
you'd go back in bed and like
like two minutes later it would go
and you're like i'm already [ __ ]
asleep again
and then it would would like refresh
two minutes even later than that
and it was like dude have a toilet be a
toilet that's one of those inventions
that's just fine
i don't need an extra apparatus that
comes out and sprays my [ __ ] i
understand that bidets are beautiful but
dude you can keep that [ __ ] i just want
to take dumps and roll out
i just want to take dumps and roll out
transformers
more dumps than meets the eye
autobots and decepticons
[Applause]
[Music]
more than meets the eye
um
yeah so
honestly don't work on any toilets
anymore ever
toilet companies until you can create
something where you don't have to get up
to go you can just
like poop in the bed and then it just
goes away do it [ __ ] yeah dude thanks
kohler
you just go where is it kohler
that's commercial baby i love you so
much as in bed post-coital
oh i love you too
hey where'd it go
kohler
hey it's not wet kohler
um
we did uh the london eye which is
whatever you don't have to go do that
it's just you know
it's one of those things like in the 80s
or 90s it was cool but like now it's
like there's so many pictures on google
it's like views aren't the thing to me
like views views are beautiful but like
how long you stay looking at a view
three four seconds
and then you could be like all right i
saw it i was here i did it and then i
could go look at it online if i want to
right so we were at the london eye which
is a circular ferris wheel that goes way
too slow and i know that's the point but
also make it go faster i get the idea by
four minutes in and it lasts 30 minutes
dude and she didn't tell me until i got
in and they closed the door on the
[ __ ] pod and i'm like oh
30
i haven't had coffee yet
there's a whole episode of seinfeld with
the commercials
so we did it it was nice it was romantic
and you know
she kept saying where's
[ __ ] buckingham palace and i was like
right there and she was like where there
and she was like i don't know and then
all of a sudden halfway through she's
like oh there's buckingham palace and i
was like am i not here
oh i'm not here
pinpoint what i said it's beyond the
[ __ ] shitty lake
um
but it was beautiful and we had a nice
time
and she drank out of a
a cup with a straw and this cup had tits
on it so i was that's all good dude got
a picture of it
british people think that's [ __ ]
hilarious i guess i don't know
oh the [ __ ] highlight of the trip
dude which i forgot i couldn't
the highlight of the [ __ ] trip
dude
this is the highlight of the trip okay
kristen is like
i got tickets to see a play
and i said which which what play and she
says
harry potter of course she says harry
potter because she's her and she loves
harry potter and she loves every movie
that's magical fantastic beasts seen it
harry potter seen it [ __ ] anything
with wizards or people who are shorter
than normal or bigger than normal seen
it like lord of the rings i'll let you
seen it right i think she tried to like
tell me she didn't see lord of the rings
the other day and i was like i'm not
buying that
and um if there's too much green and
brown in a movie and guys with beards
she's seen it dude right
and um
if there's ever a movie where guys like
to live is to and if that's how the
sentence starts she's seen it right
so
she's like i got tickets to harry potter
and i said oh okay cool we'll go see it
because you know i'll [ __ ] i want to
do that with you and and she says
looking at her phone the day before the
play and she's like oh oh
huh why did i buy four tickets to harry
potter and i say well i don't know
you're dealing with it why did you buy
four tickets to harry potter and she
says
what and i was like when are you gonna
let me in on this because i don't know
what's going on but you're speaking out
loud and she was like
oh i guess it's two parts to play and
i'm like these [ __ ] play
like
i'm like i if you know me i'm mr
watch it on a home screen right i'm like
oh they oh plays but are we in the 1600s
do you know what i mean are we in 1910
like we got small boxes in our team you
get up close and personal with these
[ __ ] you see close-ups i watch
the movie ambulance they got close-ups
where you only see the dude's nose and
eyes like we can see what the dude is
feeling so why would i go see a play
dude
right
it's 2022.
so
you're gonna make me sit through two
parts in a day like and dude so she's
like well the first one is at two and
the second one is at seven and i'm like
oh how [ __ ] long is it she's like
five hours but we can't see the first
one because we gotta go do the [ __ ] of
the london i already booked it and i
said she said do you just wanna see the
second half and i was like we're not
gonna know what's going on and then i'm
like oh yeah it doesn't matter because
jk rowling has just made this [ __ ] up
anyway so i'm like whatever and she's
like but you know i also got tickets to
see to kill a mockingbird and i'm like
jesus christ
these two plays are like the most
pleased play shits that you could
possibly see and we're gonna see british
versions of this [ __ ] it takes place
down south
and she's like would you rather see
to kill a mockingbird or just part two
of harry potter and i'm like for [ __ ]
sake dude i'd rather see harry potter
but not the second part
so i guess we're gonna have to see to
kill a mockingbird and i'm gonna have to
put on my game face and pretend like i
like plays
[ __ ] it maybe it'll be better than i
went in with you know what i went in
with
an open mind
so i remember when i said you know i
tried to read the book when i was a kid
in high school and it was just you know
that's just like why are you trying to
make high schoolers read that [ __ ]
book and then we tried to watch a movie
and i'm like it's in black and white
and i'm like i'm not it's just not for
me i've seen the rock right
so
i sit down and the theater's beautiful i
mean it's really small and intimate and
nice and we got great seats she got
great seats so she canceled the harry
potter seats and we got great deeds of
this to kill a mockingbird play
and i'm like all right you know what
they're impressing me with the [ __ ]
niceness of the theater and the theater
was probably built in the year four
so
and it's still up kept right like
there's so much gold and it's got a big
wooden set in the front like right in
the front there's like this big wooden
wall
and kristen's like is that there usually
or do you think and i'm like it's not
there usually
it's [ __ ] the set it's gonna rise
uh all right and then we're gonna see
the other the more set that they have
and the play did the thing that this is
the most like
[ __ ] pretentious [ __ ] that a play
does is
right away
right this is so this is how you know
you're in for a [ __ ]
banger of a play that no bones about it
just pretend city play when a guy walks
out before the wall rises and and and
like grabs a guitar and like starts
playing and i'm like oh just start
when's it start when the guy walks out
or or after the guy is this part of it
or what
start it when it starts
right is this going to be one of those
plays where guys in the audience come
from the back with lanterns and they're
like we're looking for him
and you're like he's over there be
beyond us
why are you with us did you pay
150 for a goddamn ticket go up there
dude that's where you rehearse
go near the guy with the [ __ ] guitar
that just literally sits there
for
five hours
and plays the guitar sometimes for
background music i'm like talk about it
[ __ ] what'd you get paid 40 pounds
and so
the play starts
and
i find myself
judging you know i'm in the biz right
okay cool
i get it i'm gonna i'll go acting in my
corner you know i mean right but i'm
judging but i don't want to judge i
catch myself judging right away
and i'm like all right you know what
dude stop just relax you're in a [ __ ]
building that was built in the year 11.
right
just chill
this is beautiful it's ornate as [ __ ]
these actors this is their job they've
rehearsed for the [ __ ] and it's written
by aaron sorkin so i'm like all right we
know his [ __ ] he did like the morning
show or newsroom or whatever the [ __ ]
and i'm like all right i'll sit down and
i'll watch this [ __ ] and i just i s i
remember i walked in with an open mind
so i had to catch myself okay open
minded up let's keep your mind open to
[ __ ]
so i'm watching the thing
and it's about this dude atticus finch
that like is a lawyer and he wants to
like
help this
you know the whole thing's about race i
don't know how much you know about to
kill a mockingbird but i guess you
should or whatever people consider it
you're cultured if you know what to kill
a mockingbird is
and uh it's about a black dude that gets
on trial for raping this nine this
nineteen-year-old
uh
woman in in in in this play and
um
the uh
dad did it the the
the ins
the dad did it
of the woman and he's trying to blame
this black dude for it
and it took takes place in like 19
whatever it is
50
40s
20.
i have no [ __ ] idea but the clothes
looked
40-ish 1940ish 50-ish 1950ish i don't
know
uh or whatever it was after the slaves
whatever the [ __ ] i don't know i don't
know history dude and um don't come here
for history you come here for the
hard-hitting facts of today
and so
i'm like
sitting watching this thing and it's all
about race and the racial tension in the
thing and i'm like
oh okay i
i get why they rewrote this for
i get it i get why david not david mamet
uh aaron sorkin wanted
i get you know and i catch myself
thinking oh i
yeah okay uh
it is yes i i know what you're doing
you're hitting me over the head
with it but okay
i acquiesce yes
it is also
still relevant today this okay you got
me dude you got me right i started
judging but now with an open mind i'm
sitting here
okay
i've got great seats i'm enveloped all
right i succumb hey guys i give up
yes
it's unfortunate
but it's still relevant today
okay
you win
now that's
35
or 45 or
seven hours i have no idea about time
in this play i succumb to it all right
and
atticus just wants to do good right
he wants to respect people above all he
wants to respect people no matter what
their race he even wants to respect the
dad who did this [ __ ] because he doesn't
want to judge anyone
because he can't what he says crawl
around inside of their skin
now we've all been guilty of that
judging people and it's what i was doing
when i sat down in this theater that was
built in the year 14.
and
his kids are mad at him atticus's kids
scout and finch are mad at him because
he's not
fighting he's not
physically fighting he's not yelling
why respect these [ __ ] if
they're racist why respect these people
if they want us dead
and
we do the intermission now there are
parts of the play where i'm getting
emotional but i'm keeping it as at bay
right the intermission happens
of course kristen has to go to the
bathroom because she's a woman and their
bladders are the size of a dime
and she comes back with ice cream some
[ __ ] how they weren't even serving it
and
it starts again the second half of the
play
and i'm watching the play
and this play is now in the trial of it
right in the thick of it the second act
and the whole play a lot of it takes
place in the courtroom right
and the jury is in the back of the room
like the back like the furthest point
from us we're watching
and i'm as somebody who's done plays ntv
and as acting in his corner right
i'm wondering why the director decided
to put the jury in the back furthest
part
of the room because that means that the
lawyers will be talking to the jury and
we will be looking at their backs
most of the time when they're talking to
the jury and i found that i thought
interesting and i thought
i judged it wrong
i thought that's wrong why would they do
that why wouldn't they make us a part of
the jury
we would seem like we should be more
involved in this scene and all these
scenes and in this play i think it would
be better
that's me judging
and there's a part where atticus finch
needs to give his closing arguments and
he was up all night writing his closing
arguments
and
in the
beginning of the play there's a scene
where
atticus says to his client
what
they're going to ask you why
you went in to help
this
19 year old white girl with her chores
what are you going to say
and the
accused
says well i went in because i felt sorry
for her and atticus finch says
never say that
that is the worst thing you could
possibly say say she looked like she
needed a hand
so later on in the courtroom scene
and one of them when the prosecutor is
grilling this man the accused and he
says why would you go in
and have and help a 19 year old white
girl with her chores when she has seven
brothers and sisters and he says i
wanted to help her uh i wanted to give
her she looked like she needed a hand
just what atticus said and he says oh
come on why would you do this and he
keeps grilling him he says i wanted to
give her a hand she looked like she
needed a hand and he keeps asking and
atticus fitch is like objection he's
asked five times now and then the
prosecutor says why would you do this
and then the accused says because i felt
sorry for her and boom just like that as
an audience we know they lost the case
right
we know oh [ __ ]
why is that bad
we may or may not know but we know that
he was instructed not to do it and he
did it and now it looked like they were
winning the case but all bets are off so
atticus finch before his closing
arguments decide
to rewrite his closing arguments he was
up all night you know scout finch's
daughter tells us there's the audience
you know hey he was up all night and he
couldn't figure it out and right before
he gives his closing arguments he's
looking at his paper and he [ __ ] rips
it up
so now
i'm like
sup
right but in a different way
not in the same way as i saw the green
knight
and i was like this trite hollywood
piece of [ __ ] sucks so sup what you do
in hollywood i'm like in britain
watching this play
and i came in with kind of an open mind
that started closing again and then
checked myself and opened it a little
bit more
and now i'm like oh he ripped up the
paper that he rewrote all night last
night because he wants to
get this accused
not guilty
because that's truly
the truth
and so now i'm like
well sup
and i'm involved
and so he rips up the paper and he talks
to the jury
and he's talking to the jury and his
whole thing is he's saying like
you know what
yadda yadda you know about uh
i was gonna say this
and i was gonna say that
and the truth is
times are changing and this
we can start to change if you make him
not guilty because we know he didn't do
this and we know who did
and
he starts going on about how
the
world needs to change okay and he's
yelling at this jury and this is like
the first time atticus finch you really
see him kind of like yelling
because he's a calm person the character
and he's yelling at the uh at the uh
jury and his back is to us and i'm still
thinking what the [ __ ]
and he starts talking about
how the world is this certain way
and he starts walking around
and
now he walks all the way around to the
front of the stage and he's still
looking at the jury so he's very close
to us
and he turns around to
us
as he's talking
and he says
now i'm already the emotions are right
behind the face right and he says
to as he turns around the first thing he
says is
we can't keep living like this
if we keep living like this and tearing
each other apart we won't be able to
survive
and i'm like
this is i i literally sink in my seat
because i think oh [ __ ]
i'm not just gonna let tears out
i'm actually going to whimper
because i'm like
he's talking to us
but also
he's talking to me
and i'm like is this even the actor
or is this the character or is this the
is this just the guy
this could be me saying this
dude and when i tell you i whimpered
because i had to keep i go
like i'm not [ __ ] with you i go
like
like the biggest [ __ ] in london
just
and he starts saying when the mob comes
after you and you're and and it's unjust
and i'm
[Music]
i'm a squeaky door in london dude
and then he
turns back around and starts talking
about and i'm like oh thank god
thank god dude
i was gonna cry so uh i was gonna have
to grab onto the stranger next to me and
just be like is it okay
and he starts talking to the jury and
now he's at the jury and he turns back
to us from the back
and he's saying to us
you know i told him not to say
he felt sorry for her i told him to say
he wanted to help her because
uh she looked like she could use the
help and in that moment you talk about
breaking and the prosecutor was trying
to break him and trying to make him
forget who he was he says that's what i
thought that he was going to forget who
he was but he didn't forget who he was
hey
and i was like
oh
word and the tears just went [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh he didn't forget he did the exact
opposite
he
remembered are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me
walls down
[Applause]
dude
i
am affected
i walked out of that play
and when i tell you i waited at the side
door
for the actors to come out to tell them
thank you
i don't mean i waited for a few minutes
i mean i waited till they all came out
dude i
stayed crying the night dude oh i walked
out of that theater and i walked in in a
judgmental place and left
and actually thought you know what
if we all just tried a little harder
maybe we can change the world that's
what i actually
thought
like a [ __ ]
i mean dude if i was i
bro i'm a play guy
i saw that [ __ ] and that [ __ ] really
affected me
i mean dude i get it if i was a dictator
in a country and that play came out and
i was trying to control the citizens oh
dude that would get banned immediately
i would take one look at that play and
we had when he said
well he didn't forget who he was
he remembered i would stand up and i
would say execute some all
there would be no more art
i'm different now
i'm going to more plays dude
i mean
i actually couldn't [ __ ] believe how
good that play was
and
it was the highlight of the trip dude
i whimpered tears came out like a
[ __ ] japanimation cartoon
i mean dude i cried like lucy and snoopy
you know
mouth all open tears [ __ ] shooting
out
and uh
it gave me like this new outlook on
life i don't know if it's even for a
little bit or what but like dude it made
me think like [ __ ] man
we should all be a little bit more like
atticus finch
and then afterwards kristen was like
we should if when we have another baby
we should name the middle name should be
atticus and this was an intermission i'm
like let's see how the rest of the play
goes you know and then at the end dude
with tears in my face i was just like
atticus it is
um yeah dude it was amazing so if you're
in london it gotta go see that play mate
i'm not even [ __ ] around huh
hats off to rafe
spall i think his name is the most
british name ever and then the young
actor in it is great the guy who played
gem and the girl who played scout and
just there the [ __ ] the lady in it
the the housekeeper in it was amazing
damn she was amazing dude it was so good
uh so i'm a play guy now dude uh well
that's it man
uh i appreciate you guys listening and
uh we had a great time here and by we i
mean me but um
[Music]
god that play i almost forgot to talk
about it man
uh
august 26th i'll be in dallas wichita
i'll be there afterwards august 27th
atlanta georgia washington dc stockton
california oakland california and a
bunch of others chrisalia.com i got
denver and boston and albany go check it
out crystalia.com and also
uh
all i got to do actually you know
subscribe to the channel and send it to
somebody dude because they're making you
[ __ ] sign in to watch our videos now
and so send this to somebody this is a
good episode you know to get them
involved in hey guys that was it for
youtube uh if you want to listen to the
rest of the podcast or watch the rest of
the podcast go on over to our patreon
where you can watch the extended uncut
version of this episode uh
patreon.comcrystallia
there's also an extra episode a month
and there's like 15 on there now that
you can go back and binge like breaking
bad and there is also uh what do you
call it another uh show that we do there
on my patreon called uh review mode
where i review different things and uh
just a bunch of extra footage and all
that and there's a community there we
have a discord where we talk and all
that stuff so thanks guys patreon.com
crystalia check it out
[Music]
i i i